let's talk about where things stand
right now in the fight against the
coronavirus and the challenges with
China as well we're joined by the man in
charge of the coronavirus task force
vice-president Mike Pence mr. vice
president thanks for being here thank
you brother why is it so important to
open up schools this fall well we had a
very important summit today a good
conference call with the nation's
governor and president Trump's made it
clear as we open up America again we
need to open up America's schools and
from early on in this pandemic the CDC
has been giving guidance on how we can
safely mitigate and operate schools new
guidance was issued last week but I must
tell you that that parents around
America teachers around America and we
trust leaders all across this country
are going to continue to work continue
to find ways to open our schools up
again the good news is 47 states have
already issued plans and guidance for
doing just that and we're going to
continue to work very closely with them
we just think it's it is important to
get America back to work it is important
to get our kids back to school and and
all of that can be done as we continue
to make sure that states that are seeing
rising cases I have the testing the
personal protective equipment and have
the medicines to be able to confront
this pandemic even as we open up America
again you know the president said today
mr. vice president that he was going to
pressure the governor's to open if they
didn't I just want to ask you what that
looks like if the governor's as what
happened with the lockdown make their
own individual decisions based on what
their state is doing or going through
and what health experts are telling them
what does that pressure look like how
does it manifest well I think today the
president brought together teachers
health care leaders we all reflected on
what I believe is the overwhelming
opinion of the American people that we
got to get our kids back to school and
so so today was very much about the
president doing
doing like he is want to do is is
focusing public attention on this
important need but but I must tell you
whether it be the American Association
of Pediatrics that put out a statement
last week about the importance of
classroom learning the the what we're
hearing from educators and parents
around America that we can't let our
kids fall behind academically but also
you know Brett you're a parent you
understand that it's far beyond
academics that that millions of families
rely on our local schools many many of
our children that that struggle with
emotional challenges or or disabilities
they receive those services at school
add into that nutrition add into that
other other ways that we serve our kids
it's absolutely essential that we get
back to school and the president's going
to continue to focus effort on that but
also also work with our governor's to
see those plans implement it the one
point that we made today with governor's
on our conference call Brett was as the
CDC has issued renewed guidance last
week on how we can safely operate our
schools we wanted to make it clear we
don't want the federal government to be
the reason why you don't reopen your
local school yeah we want to work with
local officials school officials
governors and states around the country
to find a way to safely reopen our
school I think and we believe that we
can do that for most of the country mr.
president I think there's unity that
parents want their kids back to school
yeah I do think that you hear that no
matter the ideology the political
ideology but do you believe as the
president said today that Democrats want
to keep schools closed for political
reasons you talk to these governor's
Democrats and Republicans well look I
let me leave the governor's out of it
for just a second to say there you know
when we hear some word about teachers
unions beginning already to say that
they're not going to be willing to come
back in some jurisdictions around the
country
look we all ought to be working together
on this I mean as I said at the top to
open up America we've got to open up
America's school
it's absolutely essential me I didn't
even mention the fact that you know the
academic well-being the the health and
well-being of our kids is a paramount
importance but let's remember working
families let's remember single parents I
mean for people to be able to go back to
work full-time this fall we've got to
have these schools up and running again
and working and so what the president
made it clear today shot across the bow
anybody that wants to play politics on
this thing is unfair notice that we're
not going to put up with it and I really
believe that the overwhelming majority
of the American people of families of
educators all know we can get back to
school we can get back to school safely
K through 12 higher education and our
White House coronavirus task force is
going to continue to work very closely
with Republican and Democrat governors
to get that done well let's hope it
happens today the administration just
pulled out of the World Health
Organization not surprisingly Joe Biden
put out a tweet saying he would join it
if he gets elected on the first day but
your fellow Republican Lamar Alexander
chairman of the Senate Health Committee
put out this statement moments ago
saying I disagree with the president's
decision certainly there needs to be a
good hard look at mistakes the World
Health Organization might have made in
connection with the corona virus but the
time to do that is after the crisis has
been dealt with not the middle of it
withdrawing u.s. membership could among
other things interfere with clinical
trials that are essential to the
development of vaccines which citizens
of the United States as well as others
in the world need is now the right time
to be doing this move well it's
absolutely the right time to notify
Congress with all due respect to Senator
Alexander's view the World Health
Organization let the world down and by
by not by not informing the United
States and the wider world of this
pandemic as it began in China as as
giving you no ill fated advice in
January in February it you know there
have to be consequences to this but look
I'll be honest with you I'm not
surprised Joe Biden wants to wants to
keep us roped into an
their international organization Joe
Biden actually condemned president
Trump's actions when he suspended all
travel from China at the end of January
you know the the fact that the president
did that I can tell you firsthand Brett
that bought our nation invaluable time
to reinvent testing to spin up hundreds
of millions of personal protective
equipment and supplies to begin the
process of pursuing medicines
therapeutics and vaccines if if Joe
Biden would have had his way we
literally would have had tens of
millions of more Chinese coming into our
country and spreading the pandemic and
putting more and more Americans at risk
so it's the right decision on the w-h-o
Joe Biden would have made the wrong
decision in January apologize for the
delay I want to talk to you about China
in just a minute but just to wrap up the
corona virus and you lead this task
force obviously the numbers are going up
the president wants us to focus on death
rate and we do and I'll mention that a
minute the administration critics say
the president constantly downplays the
seriousness of kovat 19 and they say he
speaks an optimism not reality take a
listen to this we have tested almost 40
million people by so doing we show cases
99 percent of which are totally harmless
we have to start at the basics and level
with people suggesting that it's not
dangerous is in itself a dangerous
message Vice President Tom Bossert
obviously served in the administration
with you health experts say it's just
not the case that only one percent of
cases kovat cases that they're they're
dangerous it's it's more than that so is
there a messaging problem here with with
the virus well look the American people
know President Trump is an optimist he
believes in this country but he also
believes the American people deserve to
have the whole story I mean the reality
is because of what the President did in
suspending all travel to China we were
able to stand up
National Response that has saved
hundreds of thousands and perhaps even
millions of American lives what we have
rising cases right now along the South
Bret I was in Texas in Arizona in
Florida last week and the good news is
is as we told governors again today we
have the resources to support all the
testing that they need we we have new
therapeutic medicines that like REM de
severe that have been distributed all
across the country and we have literally
tens of millions of personal protective
equipment supplies in reserves even
though I heard from the governor's that
I personally met with that the PPE
effort by the national government has
been so strong that the hospitals all
across the Sunbelt that are seeing
rising cases have had more than enough
PPE what they did request of us and the
president authorized was us to send
additional doctors and nurses we're in
the process of doing that in all four of
the largest states that have been
impacted so far and we'll do it in any
other states that are invested but what
the president wants the American people
to know is that our national response
whether it be testing whether it be PPE
whether it be the supplies and the
medicines has saved American lives more
than two months ago Brett we were losing
2500 Americans a day and there was a day
just recently where we we only lost 250
Americans that's a 90% reduction in
fatalities it's a credit to the American
people to all the sacrifices they've
made to our health care workers but
ultimately it's a credit to our national
response which has has secured one of
the lowest mortality rates in the world
right now you talk about mortality dr.
found she said today that it's a false
narrative to take comfort in the lower
rate of death because there are so many
things very dangerous about this disease
don't get yourself into false
complacency you are right about the
mortality rates but some experts are
saying they dragged behind with the
cases going up that the death rates
let's hope not but they may follow here
dr. Falchi also said that state and
local government should mandate
mask-wearing especially if there's an
outbreak there do you agree with that
recommendation well what we agree with
is whatever state and local officials
determine is appropriate for their area
I mean for the very beginning President
Trump has made it clear that that we're
going to support our governors we're
going to support local health officials
and taking the steps that they deem are
most appropriate but back to doctor foul
Qi who I've worked with very closely now
for four months you know
I can assure you there is no complacency
in the administration and the president
isn't referring to the lowest mortality
rate in the world as a reason for
complacency he just he wants the
American people to know that we have
made progress combating this pandemic
because of all the sacrifices they've
made and we're going to continue to make
sure that states across this country
particularly across the Sunbelt have the
resources and the supplies to do
everything in their power with those
incredible health care workers in those
hospitals to keep those losses low that
again that the lowest in the world by
several measures it's a credit to the
American people and and we are not going
to relent in our effort to make sure
that our states have the testing
resources to identify people have a
pee-peed aprender health care have the
extraordinary medicines like REM des
aveer like the steroid treatment like
convalescent plasma that are really
bringing real relief and restoring
health to Americans we just that we owe
it to the American people to give them
the whole story and while you see cases
rising and frankly some in the media
want to focus exclusively on rising
cases the American people deserve to
understand that that we are we are
making progress in this pandemic it's
because of all that they've done and
we're going to make sure every state in
every community that has rising cases
and rising positivity rates has
everything they need to meet the moment
mr. vice president I wanted to give you
time
to talk about that we shot just dropped
out for a second if you wouldn't mind I
do want to ask you about China sure if
you have a second on the other side of
this break your bet okay we'll be back
with the vice president United States
after this again joined by the Vice
President in itíd States mr. vice
president thank you for sticking around
on China Secretary of State Pompeo said
you all are considering the banning of
this Chinese owned app tick-tock the FBI
director spoke out very aggressively
with me and then gave a speech this week
about China you've spoken out a couple
of times
aggressively about China is China our
enemy
well there's no question China is a
strategic competitor with lost the feed
there from the vice president let's see
if we reestablish this connection don't
think we have him up mr. vice president
can you hear me okay we'll try to
re-establish that connection well here
we go
sorry for the interruption mr. vice
president you were saying on China well
no one's been tougher on China than
President Donald Trump Brett I mean from
very early on this president stood
strong to reset an imbalance trading
relationship that that previous
administration's allowed to develop in a
way that when we took office half of our
international trade deficit was with
China the president stood strong he also
made it clear that we're going to defend
our strategic interests in the region
the two aircraft carriers in the South
China Sea as we speak is evidence of our
commitment to continue to remain an
Asian Pacific of power and and preserve
freedom of navigation but I must tell
you that whether it be the stand on on
Huawei or what we're currently
considering with tik-tok this president
also made it clear that that we are
going to preserve the national security
interests of the United States of
America from being compromised
by the Chinese Communist Party and and
so the these entities whether it be
Huawei and and four and perhaps even
tik-tok that that that represent a
threat to the privacy and to the
security of the country will continue to
take strong stand I want to end with
this
turning to the topics that the president
brought up this week did NASCAR make the
right move banning the Confederate flag
well let me say that we we respect the
right of private organizations to make
the decisions that they deem appropriate
for their you know for their of their
organization and for their fan base but
you know you know at the end of the day
the President as he said again today he
believes in freedom of speech will
always stand for that for every American
but I must tell you that being a part of
an administration that that sauce the
lowest unemployment rate ever recorded
for African Americans that we heard
again today at our education summit has
made historic investments in
historically black colleges and
universities working to open up those
schools in all of our schools around
America as we speak expanding
opportunity zones
I think people whether it be African
Americans or any American looks at the
record of this administration and knows
that this is a president who is
committed to being president for all of
the American people into seeing all of
the American people live the American
dream I guess the state of Mississippi
removed the Confederate symbol from its
flag and Republicans in that state said
like Roger wicker it was the right thing
to do it's a symbol that more and more
represents a day in the past that we
don't want to celebrate and some of
those Republicans thought there was a
disconnect at least in in what was
tweeted out by the president you're
saying there's not well there's not and
we fully respect the decision made by
the people of Mississippi going forward
and and quite apart from the whole issue
of of the Confederate flag I just think
it's the question of you know as the
president said at Mount Rushmore we're
going to defend the great and long
storied history of this country we have
been on a relentless
journey toward a more perfect union we
went through a terrible Civil War
600,000 Americans died on both sides to
end slavery we saw the advance in my
lifetime of of the civil rights movement
at great cost and and we're going to
continue to to celebrate all of the all
of the ideals of this country the
contributions of every American of every
race and Creed and background and and
and and and this president a very real
sense I promise you is going to continue
to defend America and defend America's
great traditions against those who want
to tear down statues who want to who
want to erase our history we believe
that we can learn from our history we
can move forward together and that's how
we're gonna have a more United United
States of America mr. vice president we
really appreciate appreciate your time
your extra time thank you for sticking
around and we'll see you down the road
Thank You Brad